it is that time of the year that many
people start preparing for flu season
with an annual flu shot but in this time
of covid can you get the vaccine and the
flu shot joining me is dr judith ford
the medical director for intermountain
healthcare the sponsors of this segment
dr ford let's talk about flu season so
mostly everyone's talking about covid
right now but is it still okay to get a
flu shot
right now with with the vaccine going on
absolutely and it's you know it's 105
degrees but the flu doesn't know that so
flu season will be starting and this is
the time to get your flu shot you can
absolutely get it at the same time that
you get a coveted vaccine whether it's
your first covid vaccine your second
coveted vaccine or your third vaccine if
you're immunocompromised so absolutely
it's time to get flu shots let's do it
is this really the time because i'm
always confused when does flu season
officially start in my mind it was kind
of late october early november but
you're saying jump on it right now yeah
anytime after september 1st it's
appropriate to get a flu shot as we all
now we're all vaccine experts takes
about two weeks to form immunity so you
want to be two weeks ahead of the first
case of flu we usually don't see the
first case of flu until the fall
so yeah get it in september october
whenever you can get it at your local
pharmacy at your grocery store at your
church wherever you can get it now you
mentioned the booster too and a lot of
people that are fully vaccinated have
not gotten the booster yet because it
has not officially been approved yet is
that the case when can we expect that do
you have any information on that so the
government is saying the third week of
september that's what they had said
and so all of us medical docs are
waiting with our needles
to get cdc
first fda approval and then cdc
recommendations so we're hoping that
that will all happen third week of
september and then we can start giving
that booster to anyone who's eight
months out so i got my second dose in
february so i would be due for my
booster sometime in october so do your
math
and you'll know that might take a minute
yeah
and
we'll see now
you thank you for what you and all the
frontline workers have been doing during
this pandemic what are what are some of
the biggest challenges for you right now
so it's really been from the beginning
is misinformation has been a real
problem and so what i tell people
who friends and family is i say you know
talk to credible folks talk to your
personal physician who you have a
relationship with if you must go on the
internet choose good credible resources
like the cdc website site lots of links
to primary articles and fda and real
stuff nevada has a great website you
google nevada response and you get all
the nevada numbers and their links so if
you're going to use the internet just
use credible resources the best resource
is your personal physician who you know
who knows your health history and you
can have those conversations with all
right before we let you go just to
reiterate you can get the flu shot
and
same time same time different arms
really yeah this is fascinating
information you are great thank you so
much doctor
we appreciate it and if you want more
information all you got to do is reach
out to intermount intermountain
healthcare and thank you for sponsoring
this segment visit them online for more
information at
intermountainhealthcare.org forward
slash nevada we will be right